how can I determine whether something is
an obligation I often feel obligated to
do a lot of things I shouldn't have to
this is an important question the
obligation thing yeah you and I have had
to remove some obligations from our
plates recently our collective plate
because you broke five vertebrae in your
back and that's a problem and that made
you lay up in bed for several weeks
because that's pretty much all you could
do and with me and my gut issues of a
fungal overgrowth bacterial overgrowth
and that has created some significant
you know when your guts broken your
brains broken and so I've had some
issues with depression because of that
and and realizing that those two things
are connected I also realized that you
know what these are obligations that I
am I have to sit down for a period of
time it's weird though when we have
obligations the question to ask is like
who who told you you had to do this do
you feel obligated uh-huh or did you
over commit yourself and you've made
yourself obligated at this point right
and the thing is who told you to do this
usually it's it's me who told me to do
this right well my 50 answer is walking
toward the right obligations allows us
to leave behind obligations that don't
serve us so we talked about
relationships and serving us but here
the the the obligations serving us I
think in order for it to be an
obligation it should serve us sure some
way otherwise you know man I if you if
you show me your calendar I'll show you
what your priorities are right if you
look at my calendar those are my my
priorities it's not what I say I do with
the day but those are also my
obligations so those better serve me
they've been our add to my well-being
other way otherwise they're just getting
in the way of my well-being absolutely
my pet the answer is this being a
minimalist doesn't free you for
meaningful obligations so I guess what
I'm what I'm thinking about here is
there are even some obligations I don't
want to do but I still have to do we got
to pay taxes I mean that's like the you
know it's taxis and that's the one thing
that stands out right now I really wish
we didn't have to get all the paperwork
together even though we have a CPA
there's still a lot of prep work that
goes into
sending that information together
texting absolutely with the CPA so you
can I guess what would you call that
chipping away at an obligation maybe but
if you can't remove the whole thing how
do you make it how do you remove some of
the friction yeah it's like a four hour
work week or work week approach yeah Tim
Ferriss approach totally agree
you